we're definitely living in a golden time
for memory research we're really
fortunate because we're really standing
on the shoulders of giants but unlike
these sort of real pioneers I'll
actually have even Kandel we now have
some tools available that allows us to
really probe the brain in new ways yeah
I think it's very tempting to think of
memory as a very sort of high fidelity
record of events we experience but
there's so much like a video recording
but it turns out that's not the case I
mean all these things make us what we
are are these interesting sort of bits
of knowledge we have the aspects of life
which we're interested in but to some
extent they are not that useful but and
it may be if you remember too much of
that stuff it tells me we'll get in the
way of having an efficient memory system
so it's it's not as if we're coming up
with incredibly new theories but what
we're doing is we're testing some
age-old theories that have been out
there and we can actually test them now
using a pretty cool scientific methods